翻訳: Emi Baba
校正: Tetsuya Kawaguchi
皆さんは将来 自動運転車が
世の中に普及すると思いますか？
私はこの質問が数年後には
馬鹿らしくなるぐらいに
少しでも早く
自動運転車を当たり前のものとして
広めていきたいと考え 取り組んでいます
これまで自動運転化の歴史は
50年以上も続いてきました
やっと ここ数年になって
コンピューターの性能や
画像処理の手法も進化し
いよいよ実用化へ という段階にきています
これは我々が実験を行なっている
自動運転のバスです
国内の公道で初めて こうして無人の状態で
自動運転バスの実験を行いました
このように現在
実証実験を進めている状況ですが
自動運転を実用化するなんて
二、三十年後じゃないかとか
絶対に無理だとかいう
厳しい声を頂くこともあります
しかし世の中で
自動運転を求める声はとても大きいんです
私は移動の課題を探るために
各地の現状を見て回りました
どこも運転手が不足しており
特に田舎に住む高齢者の方が
移動手段がなく 困っていました
なんと現状では
地方のバス会社の８割以上が赤字なんです
今はなんとか自治体が補助金を負担して
バスを走らせていますが
廃線は免れない状況になってきています
そんななか 高齢者が無理をして運転し
事故を起こしてしまう—
そういった状況を目にした時に
なんとかしてこの負の連鎖を
断ち切らなくてはいけない
そう強く思いました
こういった 現場で実際に
課題を目にした時の気持ちが
私が今 大きな課題に取り組む時の
原動力に そして情熱になっています
ここで私の原点について
少しお話ししたいと思います
私は小さい頃からものづくりが好きで
色々なものを作っていました
もちろん車も大好きでした
小学校の行き帰りには こういった
コースター型の乗り物に乗って
寝てる間に学校に着いていたらいいのに
といった想像をしていました
今思い返してみると
自動運転車の発想に近いですよね
大学時代には
インターネットの魅力に取り憑かれ
ひたすらパソコンばかりいじっていました
世界中の情報を瞬時にリアルタイムで
手に入れることができる
そんなインターネットの力を利用すれば
てこの原理の様に 小さな力で大きな課題を
解決することができるのではないか
そんなことを考えていました
そして今
世の中は 身の回りのあらゆるものが
インターネットに繋がる
IoT化が進んでいます
自動車はIoTの代表例です
そんな時代の転換期において
自分が夢中になったインターネットと
大好きな車を繋ぐことができる
ど真ん中のポジションにいることができて
本当に面白いと感じています
多くの人が自動運転車と聞いて
思い浮かべるのは
どこでも行ける
自動運転車ではないでしょうか
しかし どこでも行ける自動運転車を
すぐに実用化するのは難しいです
なぜなら 全ての道の高精度な地図を持ち
電波やGPSが必ず入ることを確認し
通信できる信号機を設置したり
そういった走りにくい環境でも
走ることができる性能が
必要になってくるからです
そこで我々は決まったルートを走る
自動運転のバスを公共交通として使うことで
それらの課題をクリアし 少しでも早く
公道で実用化ができると考えています
ということで冒頭にお見せした様な
自動運転のバスに注力しているんです
また自動運転というと
走る 曲がる 止まる といった
自動運転の制御技術に注目が集まりますが
実用化するために重要なのは
持続可能なサービスとして
提供することなんです
持続可能なサービスとは
しっかりと採算が成り立ち
ユーザーにとっても 便利なダイヤが組まれ
そして 人間的な温かみが感じられる
サービスです
私は車を売るのではなく
「移動体験」を提供したい
そう考えています
車両というのは自動運転に必要な
ひとつの要素でしかありません
バスの自動運転化を考えた時に
今の運転士さんが行っている仕事は
運転以外にも数多くあることがわかりました
バス停で乗り降りするお客さんを確認したり
現金の両替や車内のトラブルに対応したり
それから乗客の質問に答えたり
それらを自動化する必要もあるんです
そして最も重要な安全 安心を届けるために
バスの車内を見守る仕組みを作りました
この様にAIを使って
走行中の車内を移動する人を自動で検知し
運転を制御します
これによってバスの車内で非常に多い
転倒事故を防ぐことができるんです
こうして作ったサービスは
しっかりと 使い勝手の検証を行います
誰でも使える様に
昨年には自治体や地域と連携して
自動運転を想定したバスを
スマートフォンから
予約する仕組みにトライしました
実際に使って頂いたのは
バスが廃線となった地域に住んでいる
65歳以上の方々です
こういった高齢者やITに疎い人は
なかなかスマートフォンを使って予約するのは
難しいんじゃないかと思いがちですが
本当に移動に困っている方々は
なんとか頑張って スマートフォンを使って
予約してくれるんです
とってもいい笑顔ですよね
こういったリアルなユーザーの協力も得て
使い勝手を少しづつ改善し
実用化へ進めています
ということで ここまで紹介した自動運転の
実用化を早めるポイントを整理すると
一つ目が決まったルートを走る
自動運転のバスであること
そして二つ目がしっかりと採算が成り立つ
持続可能なサービスとして提供すること
そして三つ目が地域や利用者に密着した
使い易いサービスに仕上げていくこと
これらの三つです
これから何年か先 自動運転の制御技術は
いずれ頭打ちになることが予想されます
そしてその先はサービスが
競われる様になるんです
似た様な例を紹介すると
携帯電話と同じです
皆さんは携帯電話会社を選ぶ時に
通信技術の高さで選びますか？
それよりもサービス内容や料金プラン
機種などで選びますよね
私は自動運転車にも携帯キャリアと同じ様に
お客さんにサービスを届ける存在が
不可欠だと考えています
これまで携帯電話が
世の中に普及するためには
携帯電話キャリアが
大事な役割を果たしてきました
各種サービス 料金プランなどを
取り揃えてユーザーに提供する
時には格安の端末を用意したり
高齢者にも分かり易く説明したり
そうすることで利用者を増やし
やがて文化として
形成される様になったんです
それと同じ様に
将来的には自動運転キャリアが
様々なメーカーの自動運転車を取り揃えて
ユーザーに便利な形で提供する
その様な姿になっていくと私は考えています
そして世の中に
自動運転車が普及するとどうなるのか
世の中に普及した自動運転車は
IoTとして
インターネットの１つのアウトプット
駆動装置として現実世界を
直接操作することが可能になります
自動運転車によって現実世界に
インターネットが染み出してくると
私は表現しているのですが
ちょっと抽象的で分かり辛いかもしれません
どういうことか
これまでインターネットで紹介されたお店や
案内された場所に実際に行く判断をして
行動するのは人間でした
しかし 自動運転車が普及した未来では
インターネットの判断が
そのまま車両に伝わり
極端にいうと人が気付かないうちに
目的地まで移動が
完了してしまうということです
別の例え方をすると
これまで頭脳だけだったインターネットに
手足がくっ付いた様な そんな状態です
そうなるとインターネットの可能性が
もっともっと広がる
面白い世界になるはずです
是非ここは 皆さんも一緒に
考えていただきたい
こちらの写真をご覧下さい
公道ではないですが
東京電力の福島第一原発の中で
働いている作業員の方々の移動手段として
自動運転バスを実用化させた例です
私も実際に現場に入りましたが
原発の敷地内では
１日廃炉に向けて６千人が働き
道路では歩く人やバス
大型トラックなどが行き交う
ひとつの街の様な感じになっています
そこでは 将来の公道での実用化に向けた
様々な経験値が積まれてきているんです
この様に私が子供の頃に描いていた妄想が
少しづつ現実になりつつあります
さらにもうちょっと未来を描いてみましょう
車は所有からシェアへ
車の所有は１つの趣味となります
高齢者でも誰でも
移動したい時に魔法の絨毯の様に
自動運転車を自在に呼び寄せることができる
寝たり 読書をしたり 好きなことを
してる間に目的地まで着いている
といったことも可能になるでしょう
インターネット上の頭脳が
移動したい人と車両の
バランスを調整し 最小限の台数で
人とものの移動を支えている
人気のあるお店には自動運転車が
どんどん人を集めてくる
しかもお店が運賃を負担してくれて
０円になることもある
夢が広がりますよね
でも私はこの夢を
夢のままで終わらせるつもりはありません
本気で実現できると信じ切っています
自分が世界を変えるんだ
自分が世界の最前線なんだと
客観的に見たら違うかもしれませんが
そんなのは関係ありません
自分が信じ切れているかどうかです
自動運転車の普及により
移動に困ってる人をゼロにしたい
そのためにはインターネットの如く
会社や国を超えて連携し
力を合わせて必死で頑張るのみです
既に自動運転の実用化へのステップは
皆さんの思っている以上のスピードで
回り始めているんです
近い将来 皆さんの目の前を
自動運転車が通り過ぎた時
私が最初にした質問を思い出して下さい
皆さんは将来 自動運転車が
世の中に普及すると思いますか？
（拍手）